Jordan is with us in Utah
hi Jordan welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show hey Dave thanks for taking my call
sure what's up so I'm in a bit of a rut
here in life and feels like I'm about 10
years ago I was a drug-addicted
it's kind of a mess of a kid and since
then I you know I've cleaned up my life
I found Jesus I've you know gone on a
mission and good for you and Wow
beautiful wife to two wonderful children
and I find myself now I'm 31 years old
you know I'm just I'm in a rut with my
career with my job so I went to school I
attended four years of university and
got a bachelor's degree in exercise
science the plan was that was to go to
dental school mm-hmm about two years ago
is when I started to listen into you too
and I got scared to death of all the
debt that I was going to go into mm-hmm
but I'm kind of coming back full circles
for the past two years I've been working
in the dental field I've been doing
control ting for dentists all over the
country and I'm still finding myself
drawn back to that dream of going and
becoming a dentist cool
what's it cost but I yeah that's the
thing because what if I'm being off on
it it costs how much for 50 no it
doesn't oh yeah well no it doesn't not
even close
your double at least no way costs four
and $50,000 to go through dental school
not even close dude don't know who
you're talking to
that's nuts I mean you can become an MD
for 200 tons of places much less dental
school now that you got some bad info
man really you need to do some shopping
with the dental schools we work with
Dennis all the time now that's a lot of
money just the same okay so either
figures a big number what's your current
income
about 65 okay that's good news all right
good so you're doing good there then the
question becomes how can we get somebody
to pay for this for you and that looks
like either the military or it looks
like some of the large and you're in the
business so you do know this much
there's a lot of large company dental
organizations starting to spring up
opening dentists chains of dental
outlets and so forth and if you pledge
yourself to them for a few years they
may pay for it but they're not gonna pay
for 50 I can tell you that but uh you
know that's but that's that that's just
not right man I mean it's not it's not a
$450,000 ticket it's not and you don't
need to go to a four and 50,000 our
dental school to be a dentist you can I
mean there may be somebody charged that
somewhere but there's no way I would pay
anywhere near that to do it and so you
should be talking about what two years I
guess year and a half I mean two years
maybe two and some change or something
to get through it but if you've got your
undergrad under you and you can get
accepted into something but don't
overpay let's the education is like
anything else it's a commodity you shop
for it and you get the best deal and
then between saving up for it finding
some scholarships and but they're
usually going to be industry based
they'll be based off of people that are
suppliers of the dental field and or
maybe industry people like I'm talking
about where you agree to go to work for
them as a dentist for so many years and
certainly you know the national guard
those kinds of things if you qualify you
can get into that there's it so there's
some wonderful programs with that
military that you can look at as well
but first thing you need to do is just
go back chuffing a little bit on what
dental school costs because it doesn't
cost that much thanks for calling in hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh